[Music]
england had a charity soccer match yes
that you participated i i i was lucky
enough to uh participate in the unicef
soccer aid which uh took place at uh old
trafford manchester united stadium 75
000 i played soccer in front of 75 000
people which makes no sense
are you a good soccer player i i am uh
you know i played a bunch growing up and
i i took about a 15-year break
and uh
which is recommended for all athletes
that's how the good ones do it yeah yeah
um and they kind of you know they kind
of convince you that it's going to be
like you know rock and jock softball
game just run around hit the ball have
some laughs right but no everyone there
has played like semi semi-professionally
and
uh and they take their soccer very
seriously very intense i was on the rest
of the world team it's england versus
rest of the world
which already just sounds awful yeah
rest of the world rest of the world
now you can't you can't
it's like
olive world who else will show up
[Laughter]
and i and i badly i i popped my ham
hamstring we i heard about this you got
yeah badly hurt what badly hurt and i
had to limp i played for 70 minutes
which was pretty good but then
oh someone's laughing
uh played for seven it was 70 minutes um
and uh and then i bought my hamstring
and i had i literally had to hobble off
the field
and after the game i'd walk the length
of the field to get you know into the
training room and
you know i thought the coach would be
like i'm so sorry i should have taken
you out because this is you're just uh
uh you're a celebrity
helping out and and but he's he was the
former coach for liverpool last year and
his comment to me was like hey will when
i saw you hobbling off the field i was i
was wondering if you're gonna audition
for one of your hollywood cowboy movies
and then just had a huge laugh and just
walked away
and
and i don't know if i'm ever going to
walk again yeah
yeah you really got hurt we have we can
talk over this you can explain what's
happening let's look at this we see
there's the play where you're bam you
get hurt right there see and you are
seriously hurt and you can tell you're
in real pain
and this being one of a massive stadium
right and then i have to sign autographs
you send autographs for everyone which i
was happy to do happy to do but still 75
000 autographs but it's so hard
yeah
i wish i wish i was attempting a bicycle
kick or something but it was just i was
literally just trying to stop a ball
right right
well well you'd think that that would
have put an end to you uh trying things
you know in sporting events but it
didn't you to promote this this new
movie the campaign right you and your
co-star zach galifianakis yes throughout
each got to throw out a pitch
we got the wrigley field uh we we threw
out the the dueling first pitches at
wrigley's wrigley field and uh
it was uh it was gonna be a thing where
zach throws a pitch and then i throw a
pitch and the crowd judges to see who
throws the best and we thought it'd be
funny if we had a pizza delivered in
between the two pitches right right yeah
it's a funny idea yeah you know it's
it's sort of funny right but
um it's funny enough yeah there is pizza
yeah yeah yeah but we thought it would
be weird at least sure and uh just to
have a pizza and for no reason no reason
pizza but sure enough the the public
address announcer starts saying
ladies and gentlemen uh oh looks like a
pizza's being
so that delivered like a bad promotional
thing
some delicious giodaro deep dish is
coming to the mound
and i literally just started shaking my
head like i'm sorry people of wrigley
i saw the footage and you're just like
no
otherwise it was going to be amazing
amazing piece of comedy but um you uh
you you got it you threw it very nicely
and andy you've thrown out you just
threw out a first i did that yeah a few
weeks ago yeah when we were out there in
chicago oh in chicago yeah i get to
throw out a first pitch
was it exciting it was it was it was
great it was really funny it's pretty
fun yeah yeah
they cheered in as much as only probably
15 of those stands were paying attention
yes yes a lot of people were involved in
sausage obtaining and beer yeah yeah
sausage obtaining yes
that's what we refer to as chicago
there's
wrigley has the most sausage obtaining
of anything yes
it's true
i've looked at the stats